black widow may feel like a step
backwards for the timeline of the marvel
cinematic universe
but the ending to the story says a lot
about what's next for the mcu
from natasha's fate to the future of
elena this is the ending of black widow
explained examining natasha romanov's
ending in black widow is impossible
without taking the nature of the film as
a prequel into account
after all we know where she's eventually
headed the ending of black widow just
helps to set it all up
by the end of the film she's got the
blonde hair we first see her sporting in
avengers infinity war
and one movie later she sacrifices
herself to save her friends in avengers
end game
the movie also elaborates on natasha's
involvement in cap's team of secret
avengers that operated covertly in the
aftermath of civil war
it turns out that she's the one
responsible for picking up the quinjet
that allows team cap to continue running
secret missions across the globe for the
next two years
when black widow begins natasha declares
herself out of the game
but by the end of it she's got a new
sense of purpose making her the driving
force behind the secret avengers team
that heads out to help the world in ways
the mcu
still hasn't fully shown us we don't
really know exactly how she went about
assembling sam steve and wanda to go out
and help people once again but now we
know
she was an integral part of forming the
group and not just following her friends
into battle
if natasha's journey in black widow is
about reconnecting to her sense of
purpose after losing some of her hope
during captain america civil war her
sister yelena's journey is about
discovering that she can actually have a
sense of purpose to call her own
for years elena has served the red room
and only the red room and when her
newfound freedom comes it merges with
all of that cold resolve she developed
as a trained killer turning her into a
determined force of nature
this of course naturally sets her up to
be the next black widow in the mcu
but her path is complicated by the
arrival of contessa valentina allegra
defontaine in her life at some point
after the events of the film as seen in
the movie's post-credit scene with her
and val
meeting over natasha's grave don't call
me that
copy thanks to valentina's influence
elena has found steady work as a hired
gun once again
but whose side is she really on does she
even know
is valentina's knack for manipulation
and temptation simply another
form of control that elena can feel but
not see
however it all shakes out yelena came
out of black widow with a new sense of
freedom and determination
and the moment she discovers someone is
trying to pull her strings they'd better
run
in the other direction natasha
angelina's mother molina vostikov is one
of the more
fascinating members of the black widow
cast because she seems to jump between
two worlds quite comfortably
even for a spy on the one hand she's
been serving the red room in an advanced
capacity for a long time
working directly on these subjugation
tactics that helped her boss
dracov retain an iron grip on the widows
for years
she seems to have no qualms at all about
this even relishing the technology she's
helped
develop right up until she realizes what
a dramatic impact it's had on the people
she cares about
from there she's eager to help bring
dracoff down and by the end of the film
she's apparently found a new place for
herself as a kind of caretaker to a
group of orphaned widows
we don't know yet what molina does after
she and alexi shostakov fly off with the
widows in tow
perhaps she just returns to her farm
helps out when she can and keeps tending
to her pigs
perhaps she digs deeper into the
worldwide espionage community and helps
elena to free more widows
perhaps she just enjoys a quiet
retirement but as long as she's alive
melina represents an important
figure in the mcu underworld who at any
moment could shift the balance of power
with what she knows and what she can do
with that knowledge
of the four family members that served
undercover in america during the black
widow prologue
alexi shostakov might be the most
diminished when we meet him again in the
present day
while everyone else has had an
undoubtedly hard time
at least they weren't left to rot away
in prison and when we eventually catch
up with him alexi's glory days as the
red guardian
are clearly long gone but over the
course of the film he comes to find that
he might still have some power left in
his worn down super soldier body
by the end of the movie alexi has limped
away into the sunset alongside molina
and where he goes from there we don't
really know he could choose retirement
but
something about his personality and his
love of adventure suggests that a
longing for his glory days would
eventually lure him back out into the
world
what that means for the larger superhero
community is anybody's guess
but going forward it's important to
remember that there's another super
soldier out there in the mcu
with a super-powered us agent out in the
world
not to mention a new captain america red
guardian might want to make his presence
known once again
shortly before his death drakov reveals
to natasha that while his red room
headquarters might be the hub of his
operation
it doesn't begin to convey the full
scope of its power
he's got what appears to be hundreds of
widow operatives around the world
all under his direct control ready to
sway world governments at a moment's
notice
fully conscious but no choices
fortunately
before the red room is destroyed natasha
manages to copy all of drakov's data
giving her the locations of all of these
widows and perhaps the opportunity for
elena and her to free
all of them in time the key question
though is what each of these women might
do
if and when they're freed how many of
them actually like what they're doing
and are perhaps predisposed to more
villainous tendencies
how many of them will simply become
adrift and lost when their purpose is
taken away
how many will want to perhaps become
future avengers or maybe sword agents
there are a lot of lingering questions
and a lot of potential wild cards in
that data file
perhaps no other figure in black widow
better exemplifies drakov's legacy of
cruelty better than his own daughter
who spends most of the film as the
masked figure known as taskmaster
for years natasha has believed that she
ordered the killing of dracob's daughter
part of the red in her ledger that she
was going to spend her life wiping clean
but drakov actually managed to save the
girl only to then transform her into a
killing machine deployed against his
most high value targets
by the end of the film drakov's daughter
is freed by natasha and elena but it's
still an open question whether she can
ever have
anything even resembling a normal life
even more than the other red room widows
she exemplifies the depths of her
father's cruelty and ruthlessness
that leaves deep psychological scars
along with all the combat skills and she
might never fully heal
but if she does feel like stepping back
out into the field having taskmaster
fighting alongside the good guys would
be a sight to see
a key point of the black widow plot is
natasha's realization that drakov the
man she thought she'd killed as part of
her defection mission to shield
is not only still alive but still
running the red room from a secret sky
base
in fact his grip on power is tighter
than it's ever been
sure by the end of the film natasha has
managed to truly end drakov once and for
all but the character's legacy and its
ripple effects could be part of the mcu
for years to come
drakov wasn't just a charismatic
powerful leader with a firm grasp on
what it took to rule from the red room
he was also the keeper of a dangerous
chemical compound that allowed him to
control even those closest to him in
perpetuity
a technology he stole from an american
lab in 1995 and perfected we know from
the film that dracov wasn't the first to
experiment with chemical brainwashing
and we also know that someone else
developed a formula to stop his mind
control tech in its tracks
so what happens now it's unlikely that
drakov simply died with no loose ends
left in that technological chain
his legacy of pain and control doesn't
end with him and we've perhaps only
begun to see the implications of it in
the wider mcu
who knows where that mind controlling
chemical might show up next and
in what form the post-credit scene of
black widow reveals that elena has taken
a job with valentina allegra defontaine
an influential woman who wields a still
mysterious amount of power in the marvel
espionage world
and that vel is preparing to send elena
off to target clint barton
val tells elena that clint is
responsible for natasha's death during
end game
which is a stretch but if there's one
thing we learned about val from the
falcon in the winter soldier
it's that she's not afraid to play fast
and loose with the truth to get what she
wants
this one scene creates major ties
between black widow the falcon and the
winter soldier and the upcoming hawkeye
series that will star clint and his
young protege kate bishop
we also know that elena will be making
an appearance although we're not sure if
she'll get to meet up with characters
like john walker aka val's other major
asset at the moment
or the power broker sharon carter in the
near future what we do know though is
that elena's willingness to go deeper
into marvel's world of espionage
means that she's primed to be every bit
the black widow her sister was
and perhaps even more much has been made
of natasha romanov's declaration in
avengers end game that she had nothing
until she found her avengers
family particularly in light of black
widow and its status as a prequel to
both infinity war and
endgame the film's trailers seem to set
up that natasha actually did have a
family in some form all along
so why would she simply discount them in
favor of her new superhero pals
you don't know everything about me the
avengers weren't my first family
in the end black widow does a very good
job explaining why natasha felt that way
and why she phrased that much disgust
endgame sentence the way she did
as the movie reveals natasha did have
what felt like a real family as a young
girl
only to have it taken away from her in
devastating fashion
the trauma of that origin story
ultimately drove her to defect
join shield and become an avenger she
found a sense of family with the
avengers and if she hadn't earned that
through them
she might never have been able to
reconnect with her original family the
way she did
so by the end of the film natasha notes
that she actually had two families all
along
but it took finding the second one to
open her heart enough for her to
rediscover the first
it's not a contradiction it's just a
convoluted journey that still allowed
her to reach the same conclusion
becoming an avenger made her a better
person and the ripple effects of doing
good
brought her back to something she
thought she'd lost long ago
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you